equip'hôtel le salon de l'équipement
atelier se tient jusqu'au 24 octobre à
la porte de versailles comme chaque
année c'est bien sûr le rendez vous des
professionnels
il nous a semblé intéressant à cette
occasion de dresser un bilan de la
situation hôtelière en ile-de-france une
émergence très nette à celles des hôtels
une étoile qui pourrait être
relativement bon marché offre et c'est
la nouveauté un service de qualité le
reportage de jean pierre enquéri un
tableau de la situation de l'hébergement
en ile-de-france fait avant tout
ressortir une véritable explosion des
hôtels 4 étoiles luxe 22 ans 1975 41 en
1985 soit une augmentation de plus de
86%
les deux et trois étoiles ont connu une
progression moins spectaculaire ainsi
les deux étoiles sont passés de 566 à
739 30 % d'augmentation en revanche le
déficit en établissements une étoile
devient inquiétant 693 en 1975 598
aujourd'hui -14 2% pour remonter la
pente
une nouvelle race d'hôtel une étoile est
en train de naître nous avons visité un
à trembler les gonesse paris intra muros
trop cher les une étoile s'installe à la
périphérie
celui ci présente une particularité il
est en bois doubs à la fois des
économies et un certain style quel prix
pratiqués nous tous les chambres ou aux
alentours de 150 france et pour les
reports 56 francs boissons comprises pas
d'ascenseur mais un escalier où joue le
décor bois et chambres occupées minimum
des espaces elles peuvent être un grand
lit pas d'armoire un vestiaire et une
petite table bureau téléphone avec ligne
directe sur l'extérieur poste de
télévision à télécommande radio pour un
enfant possibilité de lits
supplémentaires
les chambres peuvent être six à deux
lits dans tous les cas celle de ben
laden mais complète y compris savonnette
ou bain moussant tous les produits qui
n'existent pas dans le une étoile qui
sont les bains moussants les shampooings
on a mis d'ailleurs les gants de
toilette on s'est rendu compte que notre
clientèle en avait besoin
en fait est une étoile de la même
famille il y en a déjà quatre tours de
paris j'en aurai bientôt douze dont deux
à marne la vallée en prévision de raids
disneyland
car là aussi il ne faudra pas faire du
tout luxe il semblerait qu'on ne
trouverait pas sur le site de chambre de
la part de chaînes d'hôtels étrangère
surtout américaines à moins de 180 voire
200 dollars ce qui est assez élevé mais
hors site
nous avons déjà des propositions qui
sont jours dans tout le nord de la
seine-et-marne le secteur de marne la
vallée qui est très couru et là nous
trouverons des hôtels de création tout à
fait différente
trois étoiles 2 étoiles et une étoile
dont toute une palette
dernière précision l'union régionale de
l'hôtellerie souhaite un juste équilibre
entre les chaînes et les hôtels
indépendants où l'accueil est souvent
agréablement personnel